u.s surveillance satellites detected a
mysterious signal in the 1960s
flashes of gamma rays the highest energy
form of light
were expected from nuclear tests on
earth
but not from deep in space soviet and
u.s researchers joined
forces to investigate these powerful
bursts
using a variety of space missions
including helios
a spacecraft that orbited the sun and
the venera probes which
traverse the inner solar system most of
the bursts hailed from massive stars
exploding in supernovae
but in 1979 scientists encountered an
extraordinary flash
from a galaxy near the milky way by 1992
researchers had a theory for what could
have created such a powerful signal
a magnetically amped-up neutron star
they gave it a name magnetar
neutron stars are the densest form of
matter
they form when the core of a star
implodes and shrinks to the size of a
city
this amplifies the star's pre-existing
magnetic field
but the flash captured in 1979 pointed
to something even more magnetic than a
normal neutron star
scientists proposed that during the
early life of some neutron stars
their molten guts churn enough to create
dynamos
swirling currents that create powerful
magnetic fields
a magnetar's magnetic field is about a
trillion times clingier than
refrigerator magnets
and a thousand times more powerful than
an average neutron
[Music]
researchers have been waiting for the
perfect opportunity to study these
extreme neutron stars
that event finally came last year on
april 15
2020 when sensors in space and on earth
detected an unusual gamma-ray burst from
sculptor
a nearby galaxy the brevity of this
signal
mere milliseconds suggested that it came
from an eruption
on the surface of a magnetar just as
movements in the earth's crust cause
earthquakes
neutron stars can rupture in magnetars
starquakes result from grinding and
magnetic stresses in its hard
outer crust the rupture releases an
explosion of charged particles or
plasma that in turn generates a beam of
gamma-ray photons
as the first giant flare in 16 years
this event allowed researchers to use
recent technology
to answer long-standing questions about
magnetars
they calculated the strength of the
flare and found it packed a hundred
thousand years of the sun's energy in
its quick
burst based on the timing of the
gamma-ray burst
they were also able to confirm that the
plasma was let loose near the pole of
the magnetar
in the wake of the burst researchers
have searched for overlooked magnetar
events
in astronomical back catalogs they found
three additional bursts from galaxies
near the milky way
bumping the total number of recorded
magnetar flares to seven
researchers think this means that these
flares are more common across the
universe than previously thought
and that it's relatively easy for
neutron stars to be born as magnetars
it also suggests that distant magnetar
eruptions
might explain other mystifying phenomena
such as fast radio bursts
scientists are eager and ready to detect
the next burst that will send a
shockwave
through the field of astronomy
[Music]
you